erlaube ich mir eine zwischenbemerkung
zu machen die reduzierung komplexer
politischer sachverhalte auf ein
einziges thema in der regel bezogen aber
der minderheit im land ist ein
tradiertes bitte des faschismus
was haben ja heute erneut haben wir
heute erneut vorgeführt bekommt die
migranten sind an allem schuld
eine ähnliche aktion hatte sie diesem
hause schon einmal gegeben und ich finde
es ist zeit dass die demokraten in
diesem lande sich gegen diese art der
rhetorischen aufrüstung die am ende zu
einer enthemmung führt deren resultat
gewalttaten auf den straßen ist es ist
zeit dass die demokratie sie gegen diese
leute wert herr präsident
das war martin schulz mit einem
leidenschaftlichen plädoyer für mehr
demokratie noch mal rein
das zeigen des hitlergrußes sei
unappetitlich das zeigen des
hitlergrußes eine straftat die
strafrechtlich verfolgt werden muss
ja die art der rede die wir hier gehört
haben noch einmal die eindimensionalität
komplexer strukturen im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert die
reduzierung auf ein einziges thema das
ist ein stilmittel das bekannteste das
wird kombiniert der präsidentin sofort
fertig es wird kombiniert mit aussagen
wie das tausendjährige reich sei ein
vogel schiffs aargau land die mails und
vogelschutz ist ein misthaufen und auf
den gehören sie in der deutschen
geschichte
herr könig egal einziehen können auf die
zwischen antworten
das ist nicht mein niveau auf dem ich
mich mit ihnen auseinandersetzen
dieses niveau die hat das hat schon weil
in diesem hause gegeben
da wollen wir bestimmt nicht hin das hat
mit faschismus überhaupt nichts zu tun
was ich gesagt habe und das wissen sie
auch es ist der versuch uns sozusagen
aus dem demokratischen konsens
auszugrenzen
das machen sie aber das wird ihnen nicht
gelingen ja scholz
[Applaus]
um die erregung wieder auf das
erträgliche maß zurückzuführen
muss ich die bemerkung machen herr
kollege schulz üblich ist bei uns das
wenn auf eine zwischenbemerkung
geantwortet wird das ist nicht in der
geschäftsordnung vorgeschrieben deswegen
habe ich nicht interveniert aber üblich
ist es dass man die antwort stehen den
gegner